[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce mercredi 28 juin
avec une première en france et
l'ouverture bientôt à montigny le
bretonneux d'une clinique pour la prise
en charge pluridisciplinaire de
l'arthrose de la main et du membre
supérieur une clinique qui ouvrira ses
portes à l'automne plus de précisions à
suivre dans ce journal
dans ce journal également retour sur la
première journée des soldes d'été
beaucoup de personnes dans les allées à
des centres commerciaux dès ce mercredi
comme à l'espace saint quentin enfin
suite de notre série dédiée aux
différents acteurs de l'aéronautique
dans les yvelines quelques jours après
le salon du bourget avec ce soir un zoom
spécial sur l'école d'ingénieurs de
l'estaca basée à saint quentin en
yvelines 75 euros et 20 centimes voici
le nouveau prix du pass navigo à tarif
unique à partir du 1er août
la décision a été votée ce matin par les
élus du syndicat des transports d'île de
france une nouvelle augmentation après
celle de l'an passé que valérie pécresse
la présidente de la région justifie
notamment par les investissements
massifs prévus dans les transports 10
milliards d'euros est d'ici 2021 des
investissements et des promesses pour un
meilleur service
invisible pour le moment selon les
associations des usagers des transports
le taux est quand même relativement
élevé 3% et surtout
nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est que les
eaux soit se soit accompagnée de une
amélioration tangible des transports
franciliens et ce avec pour le moment
même s'il ya des investissements qui ont
été lancés il ya pas de grandes
améliorations il ya même une
détérioration sur les lignes de rer
théo sont compréhensibles dès lors que
on envoie des effets concrets 6 millions
c'est le nombre de français touchés par
l'arthrose cette maladie dégénérative
qui peut devenir un véritable problème
au quotidien et empêcher l'utilisation
de certains membres
aujourd'hui la prise en charge n'est pas
toujours adapté en france le docteur
christian couturier spécialiste de la
main à trappes a donc décidé d'ouvrir
une clinique pour soigner cette maladie
qui touche principalement les personnes
âgées en établissement
pluridisciplinaire doit ainsi ouvrir ses
portes d'ici à quelques mois montigny le
bretonneux reportage de à camille
lambert tenir un objet se brosser les
dents des gestes du quotidien souvent
douloureux et parfois même impossible
pour les malades atteints d'arthrose de
la main mais pour le docteur christian
couturier chirurgien de la main à
trappes
ce n'est pas une fatalité il a décidé de
créer une clinique adaptée à la prise en
charge de cette maladie
on entend dire sans arrêt nos
consultations que celles âgées qui a
rien à faire et malheureusement c'est
pas vrai il ya plein de choses pour
soulager les patients soulager la
douleur conserver la fonction c'est un
projet très innovant parce que à ma
connaissance il n'y a pas d'autres
établissements en france dédiée à la
prise en charge de l'arthrose de la main
et du membre supérieur dédié à une prise
en charge pluridisciplinaire et pluri
médecine et avec un protocole
d'évaluation de toutes ces prises en
charge un établissement polyvalent qui
regroupera différents spécialistes
médecins chirurgiens mais aussi
ostéopathe acupuncteur ou naturopathe
des médecines alternatives bien connu du
docteur françois brouchoud cela fait
trois ans qu'il travaille en france et
en chine
on a des hôpitaux ou en post opératoire
il n'y a pas de traitement allopathique
où on est sûr de la médecine
traditionnelle avec et très près mans de
médecine traditionnelle de l'acupuncture
et des massages traditionnels et les
gens n'ont pas plus mal et ils ont des
chirurgie qui sont exactement identique
à la nôtre on ne crée pas un cent de
médecine alternative pas du tout c'est
une c'est un centre pour prendre soin du
patient et chaque patient d'avoir une
affinité différentes à des différents
praticiens ou technique et je pense que
le point fort sa lettre justement la
collaboration entre de ces différentes
techniques et pas simplement les opposer
c'est de travailler en collaboration
une première en france qui ouvrira à
montigny le bretonneux à l'automne 2010
est la clinique pourrait accueillir sept
à dix mille personnes par an six
millions de français sont touchés par
l'arthrose dans le reste de l'actualité
de la politique avec le début du travail
des parlementaires à l'assemblée
nationale et commission se met en place
et les nouveaux députés prennent leurs
marques au palais bourbon et pour aider
les néophytes de la république en marche
notamment quatre portes paroles ont été
nommés hier mardi
parmi eux aurore bergé élus dans la 10e
circonscription des yvelines est connu
pour son engagement passé chez les
républicains la députée se voit ainsi
confier un poste stratégique à 30 ans
seulement écouter à sa réaction je très
content parce que j'avais déjà cette
mission pendant la campagne
présidentielle qui était de contester la
parole candidats l'umac rouge très
heureuse
porter la parole du groupe et voilà je
très heureuse qu'il m'ait fait confiance
pour le faire n'est ce pas que je serai
à la hauteur
on a en remettra ans
enjeu de différents postes à mi mandat
on n'est pas là pour durer pendant cinq
ans mais sur ses responsabilités la
norme encore deux ans et demi je serai
l'une de celles qui porterait la parole
du groupe et pour être tout à fait
complet et concernant ces postes clés à
l'assemblée nationale a sachez que la
député de la 5e circonscription des
yvelines
yaël brawn pie v est lui aussi de la
république en marge devrait selon toute
vraisemblance prendre la présidence de
la commission des lois une commission
réputée pour être la plus importante du
palais bourbon -20 -30 -40 ou moins 50%
vous l'avez deviné est peut-être votre
carte bleue aussi les soldes d'été ont
débuté aujourd'hui pour le plus grand
bonheur des férus de shopping les
magasins à cassent les prix
six semaines pour dénicher les bonnes
affaires au centre commercial de saint
quentin en yvelines les clients étaient
déjà au rendez vous dès l'ouverture des
boutiques ce mercredi écoutez aux
cardons repères et puis on voit après si
à notre taille c'est ça correspond
certes dans notre pris place et plus
pour les repérages vu que seul premier
jour et c'est assez calme
georges cid isna
j'ai acheté blues en moins cher j'ai
acheté 10 basket sans -50% aussi on va
acheter deux trois trucs pour pour la
titre pourra cet été je savais même pas
qu'elle ait soldes je venais par hasard
donc j'avais réservé une rampe et
j'attendais les soldes comme l'acheter
je pense que je vais mettre 300 400
euros aujourd'hui les soldes ont peu
plus l'importance qu'elle avait il ya
quelques années
aujourd'hui tous les tous les 15 jours
ou tous les mois il ya déjà des soldes
déguisés dans le reste de l'actualité
locale et suite de notre dossier
consacré à l'aéronautique dans les
yvelines la filière totalise 14 grands
établissements et quelques 200 sociétés
spécialisées pour un total de 4000 700
emplois dans le département
pas étonnant donc l'une des meilleures
écoles d'ingénieurs l'estaca soit
implanté à montigny le bretonneux sur le
campus paris saclay l'école qui était
aussi présente lors du salon du bourget
la semaine passée stéphane servant le
salon du bourget est l'occasion pour
l'école de rencontrer ses partenaires
industriels
de nombreux anciens élèves sont
employées dans les diverses sociétés de
l'aérospatiale de l'armement et de
l'aviation
lors des journées grand public c'est
aussi le lieu pour faire connaître
l'école et susciter des vocations ou des
inscriptions à la cnes par exemple
et on a l'occasion de parler avec les
industriels du secteur avec des
ingénieurs qui travaillent là dedans
tous les genres donc c'est une bonne
façon de pouvoir voir ce qu'on pourrait
devenir dans quelques années le diplôme
d'ingénieur est assez polyvalent et
permet de travailler dans les différents
domaines du spatial ou de l'aviation une
école à la pointe des technologies pour
des métiers de plus en plus connectés
les méthodes de réalité augmentée de
réalité virtuelle de simulation permet
aujourd'hui de calculer ce qui
auparavant ne pouvait se faire qu'en
vrai grandeur quand un avion fait son
premier vol c'est pas pour voir s'ils
volent c'est pour faire la preuve et
avec un taux de réussite de plus de 99%
que tout ce qui a été calculée simuler
auparavant et bien c'était bien juste en
fait on vient faire la preuve de tout ce
qui a été fait par le calcul la
modélisation et la simulation
dès la 4e et 5e années les étudiants
travaillent avec des industriels sur des
projets comme l'euro glider une maquette
3d d'un planeur à propulsion électrique
fruit d'une collaboration des écoles et
de dassault aviation est présenté au
bourget
l'implantation de l'école à montigny le
bretonneux est tout sauf un hasard
elle utilise le réseau de la communauté
de communes et le conseil départemental
l'école est aussi partenaire de
l'université versailles saint quentin
est située à proximité d'entreprises
comme safran avec son centre de
recherche
les 250 étudiants de chaque promotion
ont peu d'inquiétude quant à leur avenir
voit qu'un étudiant une fois sorti
l'estac à 80 % des étudiants sont
intégrés dans une entreprise avant même
d'être diplômé et dans les deux mois qui
suit l'obtention du diplôme
on a tient en atteint un score de 4
environ 90% donc voilà et c'est des
chiffres qui ne cessent de s'améliorer
depuis les trois quatre dernières années
enfin intégrer les notions
d'environnement de réduction de la
pollution dans l'exploitation et la
conception des avions de demain seront
les vrais défis de ces futurs ingénieurs
et l'école les y prépare déjà à magny
les hameaux la transition verte se
poursuit après le zéro phyto et les
moutons place désormais à la gestion
différenciée pour les espaces verts
communaux des espaces verts entretenus
en fonction de leurs besoins propres en
matière d'eau de plantes et d'entretien
le point avec mélanie poke et non les
agents manico n ont pas fait la moitié
de leur travail elles les pelouses sont
tondus tous les quinze jours depuis
plusieurs mois elle la commune s'occupe
de ses espaces verts avec la gestion
différenciée gestion différenciée touche
différents types d'espèces justement que
ce soit des espaces verts ou des espaces
fleuris et donc on a eu cette volonté
d'avoir une gestion plus économe plus
écologique de l'ensemble de nos espaces
verts c'est dans les techniques dans les
essences utilisées
on essaye d'avoir quelque chose de plus
durable qui nécessite moins
d'intervention qu'ils soient plus
économes en eau pour les parterres de
fleurs des vivaces peu gourmandes en eau
sont plantés et du paillage de chanvre
est répandu pour garder l'humidité
on va essayer au fur et à mesure de les
supprimer complètement les annuelles et
bisannuelles de manière à faire des
vraies économies y compris en achats de
matières premières
chaque année c'est une politique mise en
place avec des tâtonnements une
réflexion collective une formation
collective
on apprend au fur et à mesure on a pris
ensemble et donc on a mis en place une
formation avec
un spécialiste gestion différenciée
chaque année magny les hameaux investi
entre 10 et 13 mille euros avec la
gestion différenciée elle devrait
diviser par deux ce budget et on referme
ce journal avec du sport et le début
demain à saint quentin en yvelines de
l'open de france de golf 101e édition le
tournoi passe cette année dans une
nouvelle dimension en intégrant les
rolex series avec notamment une nouvelle
dotation
les fans pourront voir ainsi sur les
greens du golf national jusqu'à dimanche
l'espagnol jaune rame numéro 10 mondial
alex north end le suédois nonuple
vainqueur sur le tour européen ou encore
évidemment les français victor dubuisson
et alexander levy
des places sont encore disponibles via
le site internet de la fédération
française de golf si vous êtes
intéressés par l'événement
c'est la fin de ce journal tous nos
reportages sont à retrouver sur tv fil
78 points comme ou l'application tv fil
78 bonne soirée à tous et à demain
[Musique]